estamos en San José del guaviare detrás
de mí está la brigada de la selva del
ejército nacional desde donde se está
gestionando todo el operativo de rescate
de los cuatro niños perdidos en la selva
pero en este operativo no solo
participan fuerzas armadas también hay
indígenas de la zona de otros puntos de
Colombia y también del lugar de origen
de los niños perdidos Harvey Gómez llegó
hasta San José del guaviare para
participar en las labores de rescate y
fue uno de los que encontró la avioneta
siniestrada muchacho que iba delante mío
me dijo
Mira una casa Yo creo que miran desde la
avionetas yo fui corriendo y miré estaba
los pedazos desplomados yo estaba las
alas por acá Había otro pedazo
yo me acerqué tanto y que eso tenía
muchas moscas
estaba lleno
y había muchos Buitres a veces
rondeando el lugar Harvey también nos ha
contado que hasta que no fueron a ver a
sus mayores a los líderes espirituales y
estos pidieron permiso a la selva no
empezaron a mejorar las condiciones
climatológicas y es que este rescate
está teniendo una gran sensibilidad con
las cuestiones indígenas especialmente
por parte del gobierno Y es que la
comitiva la lidera Giovanni Yule un
líder indígena Nasa que es el actual
director de restitución de tierras y
quien se va a establecer en calamar en
la frontera donde inicia la selva para
recibir a indígenas de todo el país y
estamos haciendo un ejercicio de una
minga nacional espiritual porque aquí lo
que vamos a hacer es una conversa con
los Espíritus mayores de la selva vamos
a abrir camino espiritual para que
nuestra madre selva y nuestra madre
naturaleza nos ayude a orientar para
encontrar a los niños que se encuentran
en estos momentos en esos sitios poca
información mucha especulación la última
noticia que tenemos de avances es del
pasado jueves 18 cuando se encontró el
rastro de unas huellas de unos niños que
llevan ya 20 días perdidos en la selva y
que todo el país Espera que sean
encontrados con vida pronto